on retrouve tout de suite en direct de
johannesburg police d'ailleurs
journalistes pour rt internationale
c'est notre rubrique
vu de l'extérieur bonsoir
pour l'astag heures merci de répondre à
nos questions ce soir sur arte france
vous êtes donc en afrique du sud
quelle est l'ambiance ce soir dans les
rues de johannesburg calme précaire
violence craintes d'un nouvel
embrasement ou à la retraite chez une
femme et à winston churchill
je viens de passer quelques heures des
membres de la communauté de la police
nous sommes rendus dans différents
quartiers
il est le quartier très calme mais on
pouvait sentir la tension
les gens avaient effectivement très peur
que les scènes qui ont agité l'afrique
du sud ce week end se répète il n'y a
pas eu de grands incidents récemment
qu'une annonce était fait il ya quelques
heures à partir de demain aura un
déploiement de 500 soldats
supplémentaires
il n'est pas certain que cela apaise des
situations car il ya eu effectivement
des incidents sporadiques brèche et la
police et l'armée doit être sur place
pour les empêcher de personnes
radicaliser disent que si l'armée
déployée alors ils veulent sortir en
manifester la situation est jugée couvre
feu est en place à partir de 21h du soir
canada et les presque 20 15 heures en ce
moment quarante-cinq dernières minutes
voyaient très peu en véhicule apparel
rupture de police à faire respecter le
calme mais avec déjà été remises en
place auparavant pour lutter contre le
coronavirus c'est déjà un problème
auquel afrique du sud faisait face pour
les stayers on sait qu'à l'origine
de ces violences il y à l'arrestation et
l'incarcération la semaine dernière de
l'ancien président jacob zuma qui a
accusé de corruption accusé d' outrage
également mais ces manifestations est-ce
qu'elle dépasse pas 7 cette arrestation
à ce que cette simple arrestation est ce
que ça va pas au delà le
de ce fait la moitié des suisses à fait
d'accord avec celle qui a allumé la
poudre était effectivement à
l'arrestation ou la semaine dernière de
l'ancien président sud africain jacob
zuma en afrique du sud
au départ ce sont 6 cl sutil sont
descendus dans la rue très rapidement
ils ont été rejoints par une grande
foule qui a commencé à attaquer les
autres si on considère que si la
véritable cause et l arrestation de
jacob zuma alors on s'attendrait à voir
ton parti demandant la libération de
jacob zuma et il n'y a rien de la sorte
ce qui a commencé comme campagne
politique
parler est devenu un outil une sorte de
situation sans foi ni loi et les gens
dans les rues
essaye de récupérer ce qu'ils peuvent je
pense que certains centres commerciaux
étaient complètement oublié le reste ne
suit pas ce que tu fais ils se fichent
ils volent et les barres de fer qui
protège les victimes fait tout ce qui
était possible d'emporter a été levée ce
n'est pas une question de coût de
pillage des gens qui ne retrouve aucune
tiers partis jouent tirent profit de
cette situation pour récupérer ce qu'ils
peuvent
c'est plus de la pauvreté que de la
politique
même si c'est plus de la pauvreté que de
la politique à la presse qui parle
beaucoup en afrique du sud et qui évoque
un pays à genoux après les années aux
humains ou quoi jacob zuma est il
responsable de la situation actuelle
la population de la présidence jacob
zuma
la plupart vous répondre
je m'excuse deux personnes effectivement
que son cas il a écrit ce titre la
corruption l'afrique du sud est un pays
très riche
nous avons encore par exemple consommer
de l'électricité pendant un jour il n'y
a pas de crise étaient disponibles ce
qui rend la vie très difficile vaccin
contre le virus est très lent parce
qu'il n'ya plus d'argent pour écouter
jean m'a mis en cause le gouvernement de
jacob zuma pour sa caution
le problème est assez d'argent
sud-africaine et je ne s'étaient
toujours très mal et jacob zuma vient du
clan qui joue même si beaucoup de sunu
sont très pauvres ils la soutiennent
encore jacob zuma c'est pour cela qu'au
rayon d'action par exemple ne pourrait
pas être la solution car beaucoup de
personnes voteraient encore aujourd'hui
pour lui merci beaucoup pour l'asc
ailleurs d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
pour rt internationale